SIDDARTH BHAI: Welcome to
our deep dive on Google Cloud
managed Microsoft active
directory and applications.
My name is Siddarth Bhai.
I'm a product manager lead
for our managed security
services that span
identity and access
management and certificates.
My Twitter handle is my
first name, last name.
I've enjoyed speaking
at industry conferences,
starting with the directory
experts conference
back in 2008 in Chicago.
And I'm so glad I've had
the good fortune of speaking
with and meeting so many of
you at Google Cloud Next San
Francisco, then Tokyo,
and today, digitally
in this new virtual reality.
Let's jump in.
What we'll be covering
today is an introduction
as to why do you need Active
Directory in the cloud.
I'll give you a demo of our
managed Microsoft AD service.
We'll talk about some
interesting capabilities,
work on infrastructure design,
and run it off at security.
So let's jump in.
In some ways, this talk
has been in the making
for a couple of years.
We first came and spoke to
you about funding self Managed
Active Directory
on Google Cloud.
In Next 2019, we introduced
the managed service
for Microsoft Active Directory.
And today, we'll dive deep
to make sure we're all
on the same page.
In the first few slides,
I'll do a quick recap.
And then we'll jump
into all new content.
So what are the Identity and
Access Management challenges
facing us today?
ID and Security
leaders are still
having to work through a
large number of legacy systems
that are mission
critical to the business.
A lot of the times,
Active Directory
tends to be the backbone
of these enterprise grade
solutions.
SharePoint, SQL server,
myriad covers, and lab apps
are just a few examples.
Active Directory takes time
and expertise to manage well.
And one of the things I noticed
while working with customers
is a lot of the times,
the documentation that
exists for certain
applications is tailored
for on premises use cases.
And it's tricky to try and
use directly on the cloud.
To give you an example,
let me show you
a visual from our
recent solutions guide
on modernizing
darknet applications.
You can see it talks about three
phases, rehost, replatform,
and re-architect and rebuild.
As you can notice, Active
Directory and identity
are pervasive
across the spectrum.
But to go through this
journey your Active Directory
needs to evolve, as well.
A lot of the existing
third party documentation
will not work for
these modern use cases.
So what's the way out?
Last year, we introduce
to you our managed service
from Microsoft Active Directory.
The service is a highly
available, hardened Google
Cloud Service running
actual Microsoft AD.
This service is in
general availability.
This enables you to
manage authentication
and authorization for your
AD dependent applications
and workloads.
It automates AD server
maintenance and security
configuration.
The service is
multi-regional, something
I'll talk more about
later in the session.
And it can connect with your
on premises Active Directory
domains.
Because it runs the actual
Microsoft Active Directory
domain controllers, this really
helps you with your application
compact challenges.
First, we run the service
using the latest Windows Server
builds on the long
term servicing channel.
With the service, you can AD's
built in features, such as grip
policy and single sign on.
You can also use your standard
Active Directory tools,
such as remote
server administration
toolkit to manage your Microsoft
Active Directory domains.
It's virtually
maintenance free for you
because you provide it
as a managed service.
It is a highly
available topology
with domain controllers
deployed in separate zones.
I'm excited to share the service
comes with a enterprise grade
SLAs.
The service automatically
patches Active Directory
service, takes AD snapshots for
recovery, monitors for issues,
and replaces domain controllers
that might run into any issues.
The service hardens
Active Directory
by implementing secure defaults
and appropriate network
firewall rules.
Behind the scenes, what's
happening is each manage Active
Directory tenant comes up
on it's own isolated network
in an isolated project, it
aligns to Active Directory's
tiered administration model.
The service provides for you a
delegated administrator account
out of the bat.
And you're welcome
to come and feed
additional accounts
for your needs.
It can work alongside your
existing Active Directory
using Active Directory trust.
And the service supports what
one way and two way address.
So this was a quick overview
of what the service is about.
Now let's jump in
and take a look
at the service and
its capabilities.
Let me go into a demo
where I'll show you
the experience of working with
the service using our Google
Cloud console.
We start this demo inside
the Google Cloud console.
If you were to navigate
through to security
and then down to
Manage Microsoft AD,
that would bring
you to this page.
As you can see, we
have asked Google Cloud
to create and manage two
active directory domains here,
corporate.example.com
and partners.example.com.
Let's take a closer
look at the first one.
We're now looking at
the domain details
page of the first domain.
As you can see,
corporate.example.com
has domain controllers deployed
in the us-West1 region.
And the domain
controllers are fine.
The domain is healthy.
The security model of
managed Microsoft AD
is that the Active
Directory domain
is made available and accessible
only from the networks which
you choose to authorize.
In this case, we have
asked for the domain
to be made available on
this specific network.
One of the interesting
things worth calling out
is Google Cloud VPCs are
multi region capable.
What this means is, though
we have domain controllers
from this domain
deployed in us-West1,
as long as this VPC has
subnets from the other regions,
you can already ping up
your Active Directory
based infrastructure in any of
those other regions, as well.
Another interesting
thing worth talking about
is a lot of the
times, you already
have Active Directory
running elsewhere.
And so we support
trust relationships
from managed Microsoft
active directory domains.
As I scroll down, you
can see in this case,
I already have a
one way trust setup
with an on premises
Active Directory domain.
Know that manage
Active Directory
supports multiple
trust relationships
with one or more
forests, active directory
forest running elsewhere.
And you can set up either a
one way or a two way trust
relationship based on your
security posture needs,
as well as the needs of the
infrastructure that you're
trying to run on Google Cloud.
Now, let's take a look at the
other managed Microsoft Active
Directory domain.
This is partners.example.com.
And one of the interesting
things which you probably
noticed right away is it has
domain controller supplied
in two separate regions.
So it's the exact same
Active Directory domain,
but the domain controllers
deployed in these two regions.
One of the interesting things
is as your infrastructure
needs evolve, you can
come back to the service
and ask for domain
controllers to be deployed
in additional regions or to be
removed from a specific region,
if that's what you decide.
So in the demo, you saw me talk
about our multi-region capable
VPCs.
That's an interesting
thing about that
is that with Google
Cloud, you can bring up
your infrastructure in
different physical locations.
And they can still be
on the same VPC network
without requiring any VPNs.
I took recently our Google
Cloud inter-region latency
and throughput
dashboard, and I found
that the highest latency
between any one US
region to any other
US region was still
under 70 milliseconds.
So the same manage
Active Directory domain
can serve all four regions.
So you deploy and manage
any domain in one region,
add that VPC as an
authorized network,
and your infrastructure in
any of those other regions
can utilize it.
However, you can
do something even
more interesting with
managed Microsoft AD.
Our multi regional managed
Microsoft AD service
compounds the power of
multi-national Google Cloud
VPCs.
Their apps running
in different regions
can have domain controllers
be deployed closer to them.
And this does a
couple of things.
One, it simplifies your Active
Directory based deployment
because it's the same
AD domain therefore,
the same Active
Directory domain prefix
and the same similar
copies, synchronize copies
of the Active
Directory database.
Second, it makes your
activity deployment more
resilient to regional outages.
This is something that's
uniquely differentiating for us
compared to other managed AD
services you might come across.
When it comes to
pricing, it's pretty
straightforward and modern.
When you think about managing
Microsoft Active Directory
domain that is, of course,
the cost of the infrastructure
itself, it is also the cost of
taking snapshots and backups,
being able to
restore the activity
domain in the event of
any outages or disasters,
and other things that
go into your TCO.
All of these are
bundled up for you
and made available in a single
base price of 40 cents per hour
per manage AD domain.
If you want to run Microsoft
Managed Active Directory,
you do not need to procure
additional licenses
for the domain
controllers themselves.
For any AD base
infrastructure that you
might choose to utilize or
work with not Microsoft AD,
you would have separate
pricing and separate licensing
considerations, as usual.
The multi regional
aspects is also
interesting to build
into the pricing model.
So that same base
price, you multiply that
by the number of regions where
you want to managed AD domain
to be deployed.
In this example, I take the
$0.40 per hour multiplied by 2.
And that's how you would be
priced for the managed AD
domain in this case.
Now this has been a memorable
year in more ways than one.
Geopolitics, pandemics,
regulations-- whichever way you
look, it's been a little rough.
So you need to be prepared
for an environment where
being able to say
the infrastructure
can match shifting business
priorities is important.
And our Managed
Microsoft AD service
is ready for this new era.
Let me show you how.
I'm now showing
you a visual that
shows you some gcloud commands.
First, you'll notice
that this managed AD
domain has domain controllers
deployed in US West 1.
I go ahead and I add a region,
Australia Southeast Asia 1.
Then after that
operation completes,
you will notice
the same managed AD
domain has domain
controllers deployed
in both of these regions.
Now I can go ahead and
remove the first region
via this gcloud command.
So what's happening
behind the scenes
is these new domain
controllers have been
deployed in the new regions.
And then we have removed
the old domain controllers
from the previous region.
It's highly available
in each region.
And behind the
scenes, the service
is taking care of important AD
operations such as [INAUDIBLE]
transfers and others.
So just for fun, I looked up
the distance between Oregon, USA
and Sydney, Australia.
Google Maps says that's
over 7,700 miles.
You still find cloud use
cases where it's a mess
to try and move a single VM.
Here we just moved the entire
Active Directory domain--
no VPNs, no Active
Directory migration,
no need to tinker
with set history,
and no reconfiguration
of any applications.
You're now able to claim that
no Active Directory data resides
in your old region.
And you're able to satisfy your
auditor's needs by showing them
all of these regional movements
clearly be there in Cloud Audit
Logging.
The domain remains available.
The apps keep working.
Active Directory keeps
responding to DC locator calls
through this transition.
So that's an
interesting application
of the multi-regional
Microsoft Active
Directory managed domain.
Now that we have
spent a few minutes
understanding the service, I
wanted to dig a little deeper
and start giving you
a sense of how can you
design your infrastructure
and best practices.
Like with so many
enterprise deployments,
it starts with networking
considerations.
You want to make sure that if
you're running this managed
Microsoft AD domain
and AD-dependent
infrastructure with your
other infrastructure,
you think about
hybrid networking.
Cloud VPN and interconnect are
a couple of interesting choices
for you to think through.
DNS resolution-- that is,
being able to resolve the name
of the Active Directory domain--
is an important consideration
in AD-based environments.
And so for this,
you want to think
about how will
that work when you
have a infrastructure
running even off Google Cloud
and running on Google
Cloud in different places.
You want to think about
possibly resolving
DNS in both directions.
Cross-project connectivity
is another important
consideration.
If you have AD-based
infrastructure in mind,
I'd recommend taking
a look at shared VPCs.
If you decide to
utilize shared VPCs,
ask for the managed
Microsoft AD domain
to be created from
the host project.
If, for other reasons,
a hub and spoke model
is interesting for
you, you may want
to think about how will you
have network connectivity
from the infrastructure
that is running in spokes
and look at alternative
solutions such as VPNs
for those cases.
Managed Microsoft Active
Directory seamlessly
integrates with Cloud DNS.
So as a result of
that, VMs that you
create on authorized
networks are
able to come up and discover
Managed Microsoft AD
domains without requiring
any client side network
configuration.
How does this work?
So if you look at the
box in the top left,
you'll notice that Managed
Microsoft AD creates
a private DNS zone
in the tenant project
that is hosting your Managed
AD domain controllers.
Then Managed
Microsoft AD creates
DNS peering between
the authorized network
and the VPC host
AD domain and DNS.
So using the box that
you see on the top right,
you are now able to
forward all the requests
for the AD domain's
namespace to private DNS
zone in the tenant project.
If you're thinking of
running your infrastructure
in a hybrid configuration and
want to be able to resolve DNS,
AD-based DNS queries, from
your other infrastructure,
that is also possible.
To do this, you would look to
create an inbound DNS policy.
Now let's shift gears and
talk about identities.
There is three
typical ways people
look to deploy AD-based
infrastructure on Google Cloud.
One is you can have this be
a standalone Active Directory
forest fully managed in Cloud.
You can either create
Active Directory objects
or migrate them in
using other tools.
The second topology is a
resource AD forest model.
In this case, your Managed
Microsoft AD domain
houses your Cloud VM,
computer, and service accounts.
Your on-premises
AD domain continues
to host the user objects.
And you can connect the two
using a one-way or a two-way AD
trust.
The third model is a mixed
account resource forest model.
In this case, your users who
have only cloud-only needs
can be fully serviced
and managed in cloud.
Your cloud
infrastructure need not
leap back into your on-premises
AD infrastructure, which
is typically
watched more closely
and deemed more sensitive.
And this type of
a topology is also
very popular as a part of
a broader cloud migration
strategy.
When you think about
identities, let's
put it in perspective with
separate dev and production
environments, which
a lot of people
run when it comes to running
infrastructure in the cloud.
What you can do for
this is you could
choose to get two separate
Managed Microsoft AD domains
and still have a
trust going back
to the same on-premises user
Active Directory domain.
So this way, you can
still get single sign
on with those same
on-premises AD accounts.
And you can more easily
experiment and test
while preventing proliferation
of forgotten Active Directory
accounts in your
Managed AD instances.
Now let's shift the
focus to running
AD-dependent applications.
To do this, you
obviously want to think
about where and how
your infrastructure will
run within the Google
Cloud resource hierarchy.
If you choose to
utilize our policy,
just know that you should
set your resource allocation
constraint to allow
global so that
your AD-dependent infrastructure
can work with Managed Microsoft
AD.
As you've been seeing, we
have designed flexibility
into the service.
But you can always come back and
add and remove regions or add
and remove authorized networks.
So you can get started
with what you need today.
And the service
will evolve with you
when you're ready to upgrade
or enhance your infrastructure.
I also encourage you to
leverage our networking
and compute solutions to be
able to more effectively run
your AD-dependent apps.
Migrate for Compute Engine is
definitely a powerful offering
for you to think about.
And managed instance
[INAUDIBLE] also
tend to be really
popular, particularly
with their auto-scaling
capabilities.
I wanted to quickly talk
about a solution which
allows you to have your new VMs
come up and be automatically
domain joined and be able to
work with Managed Microsoft
Active Directory.
So I have a link on
the slide below in case
you'd like to go check it out.
But as many of you likely
know, an effective domain
join story then makes
it possible and easy
for the infrastructure to opt
into the AD-based ecosystem
for authentication
and authorization.
Let's now come to probably the
most important topic of all,
which is enhanced security.
The first thing
I'd like to cover
is, when it comes to running
your Active Directory
infrastructure for you, we
take that very seriously
and have built in
several safeguards
to help make that be effective.
First, the managed AD
domain controllers all
have private IP addresses
and run in isolated tenants.
They do not have direct
public internet access.
Second, shielded VMs are
standard for all managed AD
domain controllers.
We test OS patches
before applying them.
And through the patch process,
your Active Directory domain
remains available.
For any
Active-Directory-related service
accounts that the
service utilizes in AD,
the credentials
are rotated using
industry-standard techniques.
The service credentials
for managed AD
are never shared between
different instances.
We have procedures
in place to have
restricted production
access, even
for Google Cloud engineers.
Human access is for advanced
troubleshooting only
and is restricted to
those who are on call.
On access is logged
and audited internally.
And access requires
validated justification.
Another aspect of
security comes to how
do the AD identities translate
to identity and access
management?
To show that, let me walk
you through this visual.
You can see, on
the bottom right,
I have this managed AD instance.
And I've gone ahead and created
user accounts and groups
in this managed AD instance.
You can now choose to run a
Google Cloud directory sync
tool on a VM and Compute
Engine, and thereby
sync your Active Directory
users and passwords from here
to your Cloud Identity domain.
You can go ahead and
configure the Cloud Identity
domain to point to an
external identity provider.
In this case, I have
it configured to point
to ADFS, which, in turn, can
go ahead and authenticate
the users that are housed
inside Managed Active Directory.
You are now all set to
utilize these managed
AD-hosted identities in your
Identity and Access Management
policies in Google Cloud.
To show that, I will
go ahead and walk you
through this demo,
where you will notice
how I'm able to utilize
these managed AD-hosted users
to enhance authentication with
second-factor authentication
in Google Cloud.
We start this demo by taking
a look at the familiar Active
Directory Administrative Center.
We're looking at the
contents of the objects that
reside inside a Google Cloud
Managed Microsoft Active
Directory domain, cloudaddemo.
One of the users that has been
created inside this Managed
Active Directory domain
is this user with the UPN
sid@cloudaddemo.joonix.net.
I have preconfigured an
ongoing synchronization
from this Managed
Microsoft AD domain
to Google Cloud Identity.
We are now taking a look at
the Google Cloud Identity admin
console.
And you can see the same
user, which we were just
looking at in Active Directory,
has been synchronized up here.
Additionally, I've
gone ahead and enabled
two-step verification
for this user,
with the second-factor
authentication being
provided by Google Cloud.
One of the use cases
where we can utilize
the second-factor
authentication is our OS logging
functionality.
The step by step
guide shows you how
to configure OS login with a
second-factor authentication.
As I now switch to the
Google Cloud console,
you can see that there is
a VM here named instance1.
And as I go into the
details for the specific VM,
you will notice that I've
gone ahead and configured
this VM to require OS login with
a second-factor authentication.
Now let's take a look at
the user's experience.
I'm now going to Google
Cloud console again.
But this time, as
you can see, I'm
logged in as the Active
Directory user Sid.
When I now try to
SSH into this VM,
you will notice that
I will get prompted
for a second-factor
authentication.
The type of second-factor
authentication
that I've configured in this
case is a text message OTP.
So let me go ahead
and type in the code
that I received
on my cell phone.
As you can see, only upon
successfully validating
the second-factor authentication
was I able to SSH into this VM.
So as you can see,
there is quite a bit
that the base Managed
Active Directory
service can do for you.
We realize AD-based security
is a broad and deep topic.
And we can further
help enhance that
with our industry partners.
Attivo Networks aims
to prevent discovery
of your AD infrastructure.
They go ahead and
distract attackers
with decoy AD credentials so
that your real Active Directory
infrastructure remains
hard to discover.
They do not require software
to run on AD domain controllers
or need admin access
to Active Directory.
Another solution by Alsid
disrupts the dynamic
of several cyber threats by
exposing misconfigurations
and detecting attacks
before widespread infection.
The Alsid solution
helps locate and fix
your existing weaknesses and
is continuously uncovering
and fixing new attack pathways.
In addition to
Alsid and Attivo, we
have other industry
partners which
are all set to go ahead and
meet your Active Directory
needs across the board,
from Citrix, Itopia
Semperis, and Stealthbits.
I wanted to thank you
for taking the time
today to learn more about
our Managed Active Directory
service and understand how
this can go ahead and help
you empower run your
AD-dependent workloads more
effectively on Google Cloud.
Thank you for joining me, and
hope you have a wonderful day.